so session two from technology transfer
to agricultural innovation systems its
objectives are to introduce the
agricultural innovation system and cover
its main features some of it was covered
by Bernie this morning already and look
at an overview at the various
participatory tools that you that one
should look at so the technology
transfer approach looked at a linear
approach where on the one hand you had
experts who produce knowledge and then
they worked on how to transfer that
knowledge to its end users it assumes
that by taking expert knowledge and
pushing it down the chain and end users
one can get good adoption and increased
productivity so essentially this is how
it looked it starts at one end with the
researchers it goes through the
extension system to the farmers from the
farmers to the marketers and from the
marketers to the consumers that's how
the farming system approach looked like
under a linear technology transfer
approach the emphasis here is on
developing the capacity of research
through investment in scientific
infrastructure and human capital and
research is not linked to technology
users or other sources or other actors
in the sector does anyone recognize this
slide because we went over it this
morning so it basically looks how from
the 1960 we started with the technology
transfer the famous Green Revolution and
so on
moved into our farming systems analysis
and fs our approach then in the 90s to
agricultural knowledge information
system and finally in this century the
agricultural innovation system so the
approach in each case was covered I
won't repeat it because Bernie went over
it this morning but you clearly see that
main headings in terms of the approach
and then for each approach there is a
distinct role for farmers role for
research and researchers and what are
its intended outcomes key intervention
areas and what weaknesses do they have
so it's the same clarity I'll study from
2012 that map this typology so again it
moves from the approaches throughout the
year until we get to where we are today
and today we speak of agricultural
innovation systems and here's one
depiction of how the innovation system
can look like it's composed of primary
actors so those would be our farmers
traders and so on into the full value
chain from processors wholesaler
retailer and all the way to the consumer
what it also depicts is that you know
you have the macroeconomic conditions or
your weather climate economy as well as
you have the enabling environments or
your government laws policies and the
context in which it support these
support systems and so on we talked this
morning quite in-depth about how the
agricultural innovation system is a
really complex phenomenon in a complex
system part of that part of that is
looking at identifying what would be the
right entry points for innovation to
address those complex problems so for
example you would not go in and say I
want to tackle problems in agricultural
general you would go in and say I want
to try to trial how can I remove striker
weeds in maize or how can I look at crop
protection looking at specific points of
entries in order to address that so we
start with a current situation remember
this morning's roleplay we're looking at
from international to national to
sub-national remember the levels and the
various actors that are involved
together we bring them through this
Fennell of this change and innovation
action
to bring us closer to the desired
solution in your case ecotourism with
sustained rubber in our idyllic township
the agricultural innovation system
closes the loop by bringing that back
into the stakeholders and the cycle goes
on so it's a much more cyclical approach
as opposed to a linear approach so what
are some of the attributes when we look
at the keywords of the linear approach
we hear things like planning transfer
when we look at the keywords of
agricultural innovation system you're
here word like participation empowerment
community yeah so sometimes just by
reading the document or listening to the
policy you can actually see in which
ideology it is nested the same thing in
terms of the decision making the
decision making in the linear was much
more centralized a decision was taken
this technology was developed and now it
will be rolled out the decision making
in an agricultural innovation system is
much more decentralized it's much more
participatory and therefore it will be
more active at the local level as well
as opposed to being more Universal
whether nationally or internationally
the local population would be seen in
the linear approaches beneficiaries
which assumes a certain passiveness to
it receiving a particular intervention
whereas in an agricultural innovation
system it is looked at more as partners
or actors within the system so it's
quite a different mindset with regards
to the approaches and that comes through
in the terminology as well so what are
some of the limitations of the linear
approach what would you say
yes please use your mic for one it
follows the classic transmission model
yes it's unidirectional one way if you
need directional one way Direction one
way communication and what is the
limitation with that then only the voice
of the source of technology for example
is heard okay fine so we don't we don't
get all the voices the diversity of
voices anyone else well there are a
number of issues one is oftentimes we
fail to actually meet our users needs
okay I'm going to break the mold because
I don't like just reading slide so I'm
going to tell your story so you go to a
farmer with this blue sweater and you
give the farmer the blue sweater and say
do you like this sweater so yes I like
this weather I'll take it you ask the
farmer would you buy this sweater no I
would never buy this sweater what's
wrong with it you just told me a minute
ago that you like it
hey we're giving it away for free if I
have to pay for it it should be black
and it should be from a different
material and you should look differently
so often time when we come with an
intervention we just want to give it
away we're missing a lot of very
critical feedback from our partners as
to what it is really that they want and
the consequences that we might be
meeting failing to meet their user needs
we also don't have a focus on continuous
learning and innovation process which
leaves the communities
incapable of being resilient and
grappling with the future changes and
that's important why it's important
because the future is uncertain as we
said and unpredictable so we might have
given someone a solution for something
that will not be the problem they need
to face in five years time but unless
we've given them the skill
said to deal with that they'll always be
dependent on us
it also doesn't take into account local
and indigenous knowledge it creates very
little opportunities for interactions
between different sources of knowledge
so things innovation is created
separately but this morning when we
watched a whiteboard animation and an
hypothesis was made there it's the
interconnectedness that Spurs innovation
not a single person in this room raised
their hand to say they disagree so
there's some inherent faults here with
with this old system in terms of what it
can achieve innovation has now become
the focus of many development projects
and innovation systems are now put in
the center of many development projects
that could be a good thing if you agree
with what's being said here but it can
also be a big dangerous thing it can
also be a dangerous thing when you
believe in this that this is good in its
own sake that this doesn't become a
means to an end but a goal in and of
itself yeah we have to always remain
very critical about all of these things
and see whether they are really helping
us achieve what we set out to achieve
the other thing with the technology
transfer approach is that it assumed
that farmers did not know anything so
I've developed a brand new technology
and now farmers need to adopt it and if
farmers are not adopting it it's because
they haven't understood it well enough
so we have to explain it again it's very
hard sometimes for researchers to accept
that the reason people don't adopt their
practices is because their practices
aren't so good and that people actually
know best what's right for their context
yeah but this is something that was very
prevalent in the technology transfer
approach in fairness if you don't do the
agricultural innovation system approach
well you can very quickly find yourself
in the same pitfalls yeah so if I come
to you and I I decided what the solution
should be but then we have a nice
discussion about it but that at the end
it has to come to that conclusion that
might be more participatory but you know
it doesn't change the fundamentals but
maybe the salient feature is that today
the researcher and the extension workers
are learning first from the farmers
before coming up with with findings and
recommendations so the needs based
identification is a very key part of
this system as well and that's
associated with that it used to be that
a lot of the research was done on
research stations you know that's where
research gets done today more and more
research is being done and tested at the
farm and with the farmers and that's
very important because the conditions
that you get in a research station might
never be exactly like they are in the
various locations where farmers actually
work so it's more systematic it's more
interactive and more emphasis is placed
on the interactions between the various
stakeholders so a lot of it's been said
and you'll hear more on that the more
you get involved with the system is
capacity to innovate it's something that
gets said a lot but it's not that easy
to define how would you define capacity
to innovate would somebody like to
venture a definition or an explanation
if you went on a capacity to innovate
training workshop what would you expect
the subject matter to be not that easy
to define and yet a lot of the system is
anchored around capacity to innovate so
it's important to think
about what that actually means and often
what the literature tells us is that
capacity to innovate is the capacity to
adapt to the different constraints and
challenges with which our face and to
autonomously come up with solutions that
would help overcome that yeah
but of course that can look very
differently depending on the context of
where you live the sector of where you
work and so on potentially in the
agricultural innovation system all the
actors in both the public and private
sectors are involved throughout the
chain so in creating diffusing adapting
and using all types of knowledge so
that's a very big change and often the
innovation arises through a dynamic
interaction amongst most of the actors
so like you were sitting in your groups
earlier you had the different
stakeholders interacting that's
essentially the premise of an
agricultural innovation system bring the
stakeholders together and have these
kinds of interactions and for these
enter interactions to occur they need to
be open and draw about the best sources
of information wherever they might come
from not just from a designated source
that is designated the best source but
really what the group feels is the best
source ok let's check if you're awake
after lunch in the linear model of
Agricultural Extension agricultural
leader research through technology
transfer leads to technology adoption
and increase productivity
what is the name commonly given to this
approach a B C or D only for replies
only 14 replies okay
17 18 20 I'll buy 20 yes so this is the
technology transfer approach
what role did researchers not have under
agricultural knowledge and information
systems
interesting yes so they were not
facilitators of learning
okay which of the following is not
considered a failure of the linear
technology transfer approach a failure
to achieve development impacts B failure
to appreciate local and indigenous
knowledge C failure to promote a culture
of continuous learning and innovation or
D failure to scale out new technologies
yes the majority of room of the room got
it right but still there's a big chunk
of the room that didn't get it right
scaling is actually the one thing that
the technology transfer approach did
very effectively think of the Green
Revolution and so on yeah the other
areas are all areas where we just
discussed it falls a bit short on